hey everyone bandit here the time has
finally come elden ring the next
fromsoft title in the souls series has
been released to us at long last and if
you said it had some new stuff to bring
to the table you'd be making an enormous
understatement it's got an all-new
universe with vast in-depth lore an open
world setup that gives players the
ability to go wherever they please
whenever they want on horseback and most
importantly it gave us sonic goats but
as is common with all fromsoft games and
especially with elden ring the player
wandering around the merciless world of
bloodthirsty monsters might begin to
think to themselves why am i doing any
of this what the hell is actually going
on here only to be met with answers that
are either much too vague to be proper
answers or ones that do nothing but lead
to other questions entirely because of
fromsoft's super vague storytelling
style i've decided to explain the
characters in depth one by one starting
with the very top queen marika the ruler
of the lands between and shatterer of
the elden ring which ironically is also
one of the most confusing characters to
understand in the entire game but rest
assured i will be explaining things in a
way that anyone and i mean anyone can
fully understand so no worries about
talking over anyone's head oh by the way
this video will spoil the ending of the
game as well as lots of other stuff
about other characters since america is
connected to them all let's just say
you've been warned long before the
events of the game started and our
player tarnished woke up from their
slumber america rose to power in the
lands between and became its ruler and
literal vessel for the elden ring but
first let's define what all these things
mean so that everyone's on the same page
regarding the setup of the world the
elden ring physically is a combined set
of runes called great runes that anyone
can see upon loading the game it's right
there in the menu that is literally the
elden ring meta physically though the
elden ring is the most powerful object
in the realm but what does that really
mean basically the world of the lands
between has its set of rules within
which everything operates and these
rules are set by the runes that exist
within the elden ring for example the
elden ring has the runes of order life
and death meaning all three of these
concepts exist and are enforced within
the lands between if you were to remove
the rune of death from the elden ring
then death itself would no longer exist
in the lands between which actually
happens but more on that later the outer
god that created the elden ring is
called the greater will and it is
responsible for basking the lands
between with its golden light of grace
and offering you the tarnished player
character with a blessing of grace in
order to come back to life and return to
the lands between in hopes of becoming
the next elden lord the greater will is
more of a concept than a god in regular
terms but it does seem to be sentient
and able to choose its own will since it
can freely offer its grace to whoever it
wants and it can choose a worthy
individual to become the vessel of the
elden ring and rule the lands between
which brings us back to queen merica the
eternal who was chosen by the greater
will to become the elden rings vessel an
unknown amount of time ago before
becoming the golden ruler it's probable
that america came from a land outside of
the lands between since we can read from
her weapons item description that her
hammer came from the lands of newman
outside the lands between either way
once she was a resident of the lands
between she rose to power quickly and
was chosen by the greater will because
she exuded the three traits necessary
for becoming the ruler as per the
greater will's requirements one she was
an empyrean which is a very specific
race of people that must have been born
from only one god not two gods not one
god and one human and not two humans
that just makes other humans and since
being born of a single god requires that
god to be able to self-fertilize somehow
you could imagine that this is quite
rare meaning america was already a cut
above the rest as far as a ruler
candidate is concerned the second
qualification is that a ruler should
have a shadow or a protector who in
america's case was her half-brother a
half-wolf individual known as malaketh
and third a ruler must have a consort
which america had the man known as
godfrey was her husband and willing
partner with which she could and did
bear several children oh and by the way
the consort of the ruler aka the elden
rings vessel receives the title of elden
lord which is why godfrey is the first
elden lord being merica's husband anyway
having passed all the qualifications for
ruler the greater will chose merica and
she then became queen merica ruler of
the lands between and literal vessel for
the elden ring and as queen it wasn't
long before she started popping out some
royal kids with her hubby godfrey their
firstborn was named godwin then they had
the omen twins morgot aka margaret and
moog aka mogwin and finally their runt
of the litter named godric these half
god half man children were the first
demigods and since they were born not of
only america but of america and godfrey
they were not imperian and therefore not
able to ever succeed their mother as the
next ruler of the land after america got
tired of being pregnant back to back to
back we find out that her true goals
were much more selfish than you would
expect from a queen or even a mother her
first questionable action as queen was
to sever the elden ring which as a
reminder is her by the way by removing
the rune of death like i alluded to
earlier as you could expect this removed
death from the world but more
importantly from herself granting her
the title of queen america the eternal
but after removing the rune she did not
destroy it but instead gave it to her
half-brother shadow maleketh for safe
keeping in order to control death
instead of succumb to it pretty crafty
now at this point i've got a pause on
america's story and explain one other
extremely important lore detail and that
is that america has a special ability
the ability to split into two different
individuals herself america the female
part and ratagon the male part yep they
are actually one and the same proven
multiple times in the game with the
direct statement from the shape-shifting
statue and also visually when we get to
see merika turn into radagon in the
ending fight in front of our eyes so to
talk about merica means you also have to
talk about ratigan now it's unknown if
she already had this ability as an
empirian or if she was granted it after
becoming a god aka the vessel of the
elden ring but personally i suspect it's
the latter and here's my theory as to
why remember that merica literally is
the elden ring so splitting the ring
into shards would mean splitting herself
and these shards are normally
represented visually in game as the
great runes and later on in her story
after she shatters the elden ring
entirely we also see the other shards as
the other great runes that we acquire
after defeating the demigods and if you
combine each of these great runes that
america split apart from the whole they
do indeed all fit back together to form
the completed elden ring except for one
piece in particular that crisscross
looking pattern that seemingly connects
all the other pieces is missing even
after piecing everything together
interestingly enough when looking at
ratagon statues like this one in the
bellum church not only do we notice
radagon's extreme similarities to
america minus the boobs of course but we
can also see that he is positioned in
front of the missing piece of the elden
ring the great rune that features that
crisscross pattern of a bunch of exes i
believe this proves to us that similar
to how america doesn't just possess the
elden ring but literally is the elden
ring radagon doesn't just possess a
shard of the elden ring but rather is
literally a great rune that merica split
apart from herself complete with his own
body and personality as proven to us by
the fact that america's hammer tells us
that america shattered the elden ring
but radagon attempted to repair it
proving they have different
consciousnesses confused great let's
keep going the question is why did
merika split ratagon apart from herself
well once america was queen of the land
and after making herself immortal she
began to wage wars and i believe she
split ratagon into his own being in
order to have herself serve herself as
the head of her host of armies which is
said was the entire purpose behind
ratagan's appearance in the lands
between the first war that merica waged
was with the fire giants of the north
who were in service to another god that
granted them their powers can't have
that of course so america and her hubby
godfrey and her armies led by ratagon
went up there and killed their god the
fire giants who all had flaming red hair
and were pissed at the whole losing
their god thing in turn cursed ratigan a
curse that resulted in ratigan having
red hair previously ratigan had golden
hair just like merica so apparently this
pissed him off america then cursed the
fire giants right back with making them
forever tend to their flames which is
apparently a bad thing anyway there were
still other giants to clear up including
their leader but at this point marica
sent ratigan and her host of armies back
down to the south to fight against the
carrion royal family who were a group of
people that similarly to the fire giants
worshipped the moon and saw it as equal
to the stars the robes proved to us that
their belief in the moon was heralded as
heresy so of course america can't have
that ratigan and the golden host ward
against the head of both the carrion
royal family and the academy of raya
lucaria a woman by the name of ranala
queen of the full moon according to the
description of one of the royal carion
knight swords apparently even though
rinaldo's forces were much smaller in
size than the golden host they still
proved a match through sorcerous battle
skills but in a twist of fate that
nobody saw coming ratagan who was
fighting against ranala instead stops
fighting her and falls in love with her
and then marries her strangely enough
even though ratigan is born of the elden
ring and therefore exists as an
embodiment of the moon's opposition
given that his other half america
heralded all this stuff as heresy he
himself was pretty open-minded as
husband to ranala he actually studied
her sorcery moon magic and as husband to
america which is something we'll get to
in a second he studied her incantations
after they were married ratagan just
moved on in with ronald and lived in the
academy which is why his wolf is still
there when the player tarnished his
explorer in the area while living with
his new wife ranalla and while his other
self is waging a war with the giants in
the north ratagon just decides to get
busy and starts having kids with ranala
together they make the following babies
radon who grew up to be general radon
who was visually designed to resemble
ganondorf which i think is super cool
reichard and absolute weirdo and ronnie
the witch although she calls herself an
empyrean while radon and reichardt are
not so her being born of ranala is
currently still debatable after ronald's
children are born america in the
meantime finally has godfrey kill the
giant stormlord and right after that she
removes his grace from him and banishes
him from the lands between to become the
first tarnished which is like super
harsh especially since godfrey the first
elden lord clearly only loved and served
his wife merika and ended up getting
banished for doing his job but i think
she did this because not only had he
served his purpose but she also found
out that ratagan her other self could
also produce children meaning she didn't
need godfrey or anyone else to produce a
worthy heir in case anything were to
happen to her her real lover was herself
all along and once ratigan heard of
godfrey's banishment he up and leaves
his family and ranala in order to go
make babies with himself herself
themselves i don't know it's kind of
weird it is said that ronald's heart
left with him meaning she was
understandably heartbroken but it's okay
because ratagan made a new great rune
one of unborn children that exists in
the form of an egg and gave it to her
cause that fixes everything spoiler
alert it doesn't and she still can't get
over him to this day anyway when radagon
returned to america and became elden
lord number two they married themselves
and got busy pretty quickly and popped
out a pair of beautiful little babbitt
twins named mikela and millenia one of
which you probably recognize from this
extremely cool trailer scene and who
both unfortunately were born with some
pretty bad defects like being an eternal
child in michela's case or having rot
inside your body in millennia's case
which could be because they were in
bread maybe it's not explained why but
what's special about these two is that
since they are born of only one god they
are america's first empyrean offspring
besides ranny that is but like i said
her birth is another theory in and of
itself speaking of randy though after
many years pass and the young witch girl
ages to at least semi-adulthood she's
randomly chosen by the two fingers which
are the speakers of the greater will to
be groomed into replacing america as the
new vessel of the elden ring because
even though america is supposed to be
eternal at this point apparently the
greater will had other plans the thing
is ronnie isn't so keen about the
greater will or its golden order and she
decides she actually wants nothing to do
with it but she also knew that with her
immortal imperial flesh she would never
be able to escape the pressuring of the
greater will exerting its will over her
will so she decides to prevent it in a
very dramatic way by literally
committing suicide with the rune of
death so she learned of where it was and
she stole it from malaketh and used it
to craft black knives from the death
rune and on the night of the black
knives she had herself killed releasing
her soul from her body which is why she
now inhabits the body of a doll instead
now what does this have to do with
america i hear you wondering well it
just so happens that on that night the
night of the black knives another
demigod was also killed godwin remember
godwin america and godfrey's firstborn
son an all-around good guy and
subsequently america's favorite was
murdered but for some reason instead of
his body being killed and his soul
released his soul was killed and his
body was released which leads to all
sorts of other events that i don't have
time to go to in this video it's unknown
if ronnie ordered the murder of godwin
since she's the one who made the black
knives and it happened on the same night
under her command at least in part or if
the black knife assassins did it of
their own volition but again i'm not
going to delve into too much non-america
lore since that would make this video
much much longer anyway america becomes
quite upset at the murder of her
favorite child and also at the death of
ronnie who was the only whole
non-tainted child of hers that could
possibly succeed her after her reign was
over now you might be wondering why
should she be worried about a successor
if she herself is eternal like i was
mentioning earlier this isn't answered
directly but i personally believe that
since the two fingers aka the greater
will was trying to groom ronnie into
becoming the next vessel of the elden
ring it can be assumed that it was none
other than the greater will itself who
was going to enforce the end of
america's reign remember that the
greater will never intended on death
being separated from life that was
america thing so either the greater will
was now of the opinion that merica
should be dead at this point or it just
had a problem with her and no longer
believed she was fit to rule thus
attempting to groom ronnie as america's
replacement so to revolt against the
will of the greater will and remain the
ruler forever america then shatters the
elden ring bringing absolute chaos to
the world and shattering her own body in
the process now it's pretty obvious that
america and the greater will are not
aligned with one another and given
merica's selfish actions with repeatedly
altering the elden ring to her own
desires and some very ominous
information that we can read from
gideon's armor which says that when he
saw america's true will he shuddered in
fear at the end which should not be
clearly america had something terrifying
in mind for the land of the lands
between and its people within although
what it was specifically we can't
presently determine without extreme
jumps of speculation at this point
ratigan who is known as ratigan of the
golden order by the way and who was born
of the elden ring with a mind of his own
that is allied with the greater will in
contrast to america reforges himself
back into the elden ring back into
america's body doing this returned his
shard to the ring and restored some
order to the world preventing its
absolute collapse leading me to believe
that ratigan of the golden order may
have possessed the great rune of order
the crisscross pattern that connected
all the others after this for the rest
of the story both america and ratigan
exist within the same body with the
other shards scattered and resting with
america's non-imperial demigod children
the greater will had no choice but to
keep her as the elden rings vessel for
the foreseeable future because it's not
like they have a bunch of potential
imperial replacements after ratigan's
re-merging with the elden ring aka
america therefore removing the second
elden lord from existence the greater
will began to get desperate for someone
to do something about repairing the
shards of the elden ring and it's at
this point that the greater will itself
extends its grace to the tarnished which
includes you the player the events of
the game follow which in a nutshell is
summed up by saying the player tarnished
reclaims all the shards of the olden
ring by killing all of america's demigod
children and ends the game by repairing
the elden ring aka merika and ruling
alongside the imprisoned god as the
elden lord there are other optional
endings which mostly include adding
different runes to the repaired elden
ring in order to alter the way the world
will work for the next dozen millennia
or so but one other optional ending
actually does away with america and the
elden ring for good and it all revolves
around ranny the witch ushering in the
era of moonlight but that's something
i'll cover in a separate video since
this one is already way too long so be
sure to let me know in the comments
below whether or not you'd like to see
randy's story explained by yours truly
and that wraps up the story of america
complete from start to finish but with a
game as vast as elder ring it is
possible that i forgot something or
maybe missed a piece of lore that could
have changed my outcome if you know of
anything like this i'd love to read
about it in the comments below also
thank you so much for watching i've been
wanting to talk about eldon ring for so
long on the channel and it feels so good
to finally have officially begun
covering this game this video required
lots of hours of research so please
consider leaving a like if you enjoyed
the video as it really helps it out on
the algorithm and subscribe if you
haven't already to stick around for all
the other videos to come huge thanks as
always to my bandit crew who make my day
every day and that's about it hope you
guys have a wonderful rest of your day
and that you continue to enjoy the
spectacle that is out in ring game of
the year 2022 calling you right now
anyway this is bandit looking forward to
seeing you next time and signing out
peace
[Music]
you